[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur rt france très
heureuse de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de la grande interview
notre invité aujourd'hui philippe
froguel qui est professeur de médecine
génomique et à la une période college de
londres
il exerce également au chu de lille qui
est classé parmi les meilleurs hôpitaux
de france généticien de classe
internationale philippe froguel s'est
beaucoup exprimée ces derniers mois sur
la gestion du coronavirus philippe
froguel bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur la france bonjour
merci alors tout au long de cette crise
sanitaire convient et dont on est loin
du mal à se sortir
actuellement le public a vu le grand
public en tout cas a vu émerger tout un
ensemble de controverses scientifiques
entre les pro et les anti raout les pros
masque anti masque on a aussi vu des
débats pro hydroxy chloroquine ou rem
désir d'ailleurs récemment le sénateur
et médecin bernard jonnier a déclaré
excédé le débat scientifique ne peut pas
devenir politique
ne parlons plus de ce sujet justesse de
la science tranche la question vous en
tant que chercheur est ce que vous
pensez que le débat scientifique doit
rester aux scientifiques
le débat scientifique et appartient à
tout le monde
nous nous sommes là pour dire la science
en tout cas la science laquelle on croit
parce qu'en réalité la science est
souvent difficile un terme à interpréter
mais ensuite le grand public puisque on
s'adresse à lui via les les différentes
chaînes d'information il est normal
qu'ils puissent dire ce qu'ils veulent
et les hommes politiques sont partis
durant public justement parlons des
chaînes d'information des médias quel
est notre rôle à nous mais diakaye le
rôle qu'on doit jouer dans cette triste
sanitaires les chaînes d'information
continue sont là pour donner
l'information aux gens qui en font ce
qu'ils veulent et nous nous sommes dit
sorte de grand témoin et on est là pour
dire des choses dans le domaine de
l'expertisé et vous avez l'impression
d'être entendu d'un coup
rit on est écouté ça c'est sûr est-ce
qu'on ait compris ça dépend il faut dire
que beaucoup de mes collègues ont changé
d'avis tellement souvent que les gens
sont un peu perdus ou alors est ce que
il ya finalement un problème entre le
temps médiatique et le temps de la
recherche c'est comme ça que vous
expliquer ce phénomène
d'abord une grande partie d'entre nous
n'en font pas de recherche
c'est pas parce que vous êtes professeur
de médecine que vous faites de la
recherche environ les deux tiers de mes
collègues professeurs même à paris sont
très très peu de science et donc les
médias font une erreur entre se défend
de la science qui a un temps long et
puis ceux qui disent des choses vues de
vue leurs expériences et là c'est
beaucoup plus rapide
alors est ce que quelque part c'est pas
aussi le rôle des médias peut-être de
montrer que que dans la recherche
finalement il ya des discussions des
désaccords est-ce que c'est pas drôle de
montrer ça aussi oui il ya toujours eu
des des grands désaccords entre
scientifiques
on l'a vu par exemple pour galilée on
l'a vu pour une stein et la relativité
et la physique quantique
ça a toujours existé et ça existera
toujours mais il n'y avait pas les
chaînes d'information continue philippe
roberge avait aussi une question à vous
poser concernant des fraudes un
scientifique ou des erreurs
scientifiques qui ont éclaboussé des
revues présenté jusque là comme
prestigieuses je pense notamment à
zealand 7 ou à la new england journal of
medecine qui ont publié en fait des
études à charge contre l'hydre auxi
chloroquine ce qui avait même conduit à
l'arrêt par l' oms de plusieurs essais
cliniques sur l'intérêt de ce médicament
alors deux questions
tout d'abord quel est le poids est
l'intérêt de ces revues pour vous en
tant que chercheur et pour nous les
médias mais aussi pour le grand public
peut-on encore faire confiance à ces
institutions scientifiques 1
ces deux revues sont les revues les plus
connus en recherche clinique
c'est-à-dire des recherches médicales
appliquées et ils ont joué un rôle
important mais en même temps ils ont
publié un peu trop rapidement
de temps en temps le land 7 c'est un
petit peu un le sun
c'est à dire c'est un tabloïd et là
effectivement ils ont fait n'importe
quoi
vous êtes quand même en train de
comparer une revue scientifique
considérées comme prestigieuses arts
magazine people
dans certains cas ce sont des magazines
people et ils font du chiffre
ce sont des sociétés extrêmement
lucrative et donc ils ont une stratégie
business et marketing comme les autres
donc là vous dites on grand public ne
fait pas forcément confiance à ces
revues alors ces revues en temps
ordinaire sont très contrôlés parce
qu'ils n'ont pas intérêt à publier des
choses fausses ça arrive quand même de
le faire mais là c'est évident qu'ils
ont publiée n'importe quoi pour faire le
pour faire le buzz
on a quand même le ms qui a suivi en
fait cette étude et kaka me retirer
c'étaient les essais cliniques étaient
en cours en fait pour l'hydraulique
l'origine après cette étude qui a été
publiée par the land 7
on parle de l'om est de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
oui à vélo oms au début c'était
l'organisation chinoise de la santé fut
ensuite suite il en suit levant ils ont
aucun spécialiste au réel et ils sont
très proches des gouvernements et donc
moi je me méfie souvent de ce que dit le
riz maïs
la seule chose d'intelligent qu'ils ont
dit c'est tester tester tester on
comprenait que en tant que chercheur en
tant que scientifique quand vous tenez
ces propos ça fait peut-être écho aussi
à une certaine défiance de la population
vis-à-vis des scientifiques comme on a
pu le voir ces derniers mois pendant
cette crise sanitaire
oui tout à fait mais sachez quand même
que ce virus était inconnu ian
totalement inconnu on n'imaginait même
pas qui les a dérivé
donc tout le monde a été perdu et comme
vous vous existez que vous ne demandez à
traves i et ii des gens qui connaissent
encore moins que nous eh bien on se
retrouve avec tout et n'importe quoi
tout à l'heure on a parlé de confiance
est là je parle de conflit d'intérêt
entre c'est un certain nombre de
scientifiques est là
industrie pharmaceutique on a entendu
notamment des critiques sur la question
de l' usage de l'hydroxyde leur quine ou
du renne désir quelle est votre position
à vous sur ce sujet qui est comme
sensibles le corps médical français
surtout ce qu'on appelle les opinions de
leader ou les qui opine leaders qui sont
des choses considéré par l'industrie
important dans la stratégie de marketing
montre coeur en réalité il ya des liens
très proches entre de nombreux collègues
et l'industrie et donc ça pollue un peu
le débat c'est pas parce que vous avez
été invité à des congrès par gillet hâte
que vous êtes vendu agir ead
mais d'un autre côté si vous avez
travaillé avec eux vous êtes très
ouverts à ce qu'ils vous disent alors
justement en juillet dernier
l'infectiologue karine lacombe a
expliqué en substance qu'il ne fallait
pas confondre liens d'intérêt avec
conflit d'intérêt mme prix nous
expliquer la nuance comment est ce qu'il
faut entendre cette nuance comme de la
mauvaise foi écoutez moi un des patrons
quand j'étais jeune j'ai été invité par
un labo qui s'appelait servier et
j'étais très content et il m'a dit il
n'y a pas de repas gratuits
un jour tu passeras lagaize et donc les
liens d'un terrain conduisent souvent à
des à des conflits d'intérêts conflits
d'intérêts ça veut pas dire que dire que
vous êtes une crapule
ça veut dire que vous devez faire très
attention que ce que vous allez dire et
faire n'est pas influencée par des gens
qui nous ont donné de l'argent et est ce
que vous pensez que dans le cas précis
de ces crises du coronavirus le public a
raison de penser qu'il y à des conflits
d'intérêts et à raison de se méfier
finalement de ce qu'on lui annonce il
est absolument clair que pour leur md et
vire gillet al dahab et déco des
contacts très important
avec les infectiologues mondiaux et que
ça beaucoup aidé pour que la fda et
l'agencé européenne
les autorise il a été montré récemment
qu'ils avaient accès aux résultats des
grandes études internationales a avant
tout le monde ce qui alors permis de
faire du lobbying et donc ça fait pas
bon il faut quand même préciser pour nos
téléspectateurs que gilead c'est le
laboratoire qui produit le raid désir
qui est actuellement dans les débats y
qui est souvent opposé à l'hydroxyethyl
orkin hydroxyque la hot line est un
générique il ya aucun intérêt financier
particuliers là-dessus et sanofi n'a pas
vraiment défendu défendu l'hydroxyde
leur équipe puisqu'il ya une pas
d'argent nature julian c'est autre chose
donc vous aujourd'hui philippe froguel
vous nous dites
finalement il y a des intérêts si on met
en avant en fait finalement le règne de
sévir aujourd'hui c'est parce que
derrière il ya des intérêts financiers
très clair et précis lorraine décision
ne sert à rien et il a des effets
secondaires très important ça a été
vraiment montré partout et si ça a été
autorisé c'est parce que cette
entreprise avec ses soutiens a permis
d'avoir l'autorisation avant que la
l'absence d'effet soit évident qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire finalement pour nous de
retrouver la confiance du public
vis-à-vis de la recherche scientifique
et éviter le finalement souri tous
corrompus
il faut que le public comprenne quelque
en réalité les choses sont difficiles
quand il s'agit de nouvelles maladies et
qu'il n'y a pas de choses évidentes et
on le voit bien la personne n'a pu
prévoir ce qui allait se passer
réellement on a peu de traitements
efficaces
on n'a toujours pas de vaccin et
personne ne sait exactement ce qu'il
faut faire et donc les scientifiques qui
sont comme tout le monde comme les
politiques et on travaille à sept
joueurs et les épidémiologistes qui vous
disent qu'ils veulent
ils savent ce qui va se passer là c'est
dans un mois et ils se trompent boyle
vous trompe
en réalité ça va comme la météo ce qui
va se passer la semaine prochaine
donc on regarde ce qu'on évoquait en
début de cet entretien il ya une
différence entre le temps médiatique
finalement le temps scientifique le
temps de la recherche et il faut une
humilité
quand on est un scientifique car les
choses sont compliquées pas toujours
établi définitivement
on arrive déjà à la fin de la première
partie de cette interview on va faire
une courte pause et on vous retrouve
tout de suite pour un entretien avec
philippe froguel
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande île interview
avec philippe froguel généticien de
classe mondiale vous collaborez un essai
clinique pour vérifier l'efficacité
d'une molécule contre lakovic 19
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur cette molécule est compté ce qu'elle
va arriver si elle s'avère efficace
alors mon collègue benoît déprez a
commencé à travailler dès le début du
confinement des derniers confinement
pour tester 2000 médicaments connus pour
essayer de voir si on pouvait les
repositionner avec une activité
antivirale et effectivement il y en a
plusieurs qui ont été retrouvés dont
leur md et vire et et puis un autre qui
était une molécule qui n'est plus dans
le commerce en france mais que je
connais bien pour l'avoir prescrite
quand je faisais de la médecine générale
pour les rhinopharyngites et qui est
très efficace dans les tubes et sur les
épithélium bronchique humains
reconstituer c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle des organes aux ide
apparemment ils marchent bien sans
effets secondaires connus et à des doses
qui correspondent à ce qu'on a quand on
on compte on donnait le médicament
maintenant il faut prouver que sa marque
contre ce virus réellement avec des
vrais gens aient commencé à saisir
regarde comment ça se passe en fait le
processus à vous en êtes à qualité
alors ça a été un peu long parce que mes
collègues ont essayé d'avoir de l'argent
pour faire cette étude cette étude n'est
pas une étude habituels comme toutes
celles qui ont été faites sur le vide
parce qu' elle n'est pas affaire à
l'hôpital elle fr à faire ce qu'on dit
en ville puisque cet antiviral pour être
utile et il doit être donné avant qu'on
soit à l'hôpital parce que comme tous
les gens sont l'hôpital il ya déjà plus
de virus donc ça sert à rien de donner
un anti un antiviral ils ont eu du mal à
trouver de l'argent mes collègues de
l'institut pasteur pour ça parce que
personne vouloir donner de l'argent
et finalement après une campagne
médiatique un appel au président macron
bernard arnault qui est d'origine de
roubaix dans la métropole lilloise a
donné avec son sa société 5 millions
d'euros qui vont permettre de faire le
travail donc on en est à aujourd'hui
avoir les autorisations pour faire cette
étude et d'hector nara les autorisations
avons commencé à faire à faire le
travail et à prendre des gens qui
viennent juste d'être diagnostiqués
positifs et leur donner amaury tulle et
de voir si ça marche ou pas alors vous
avez évoqué ce don de lvmh de bernard
arnault de 5 millions d'euros il me
semble est ce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui en france la recherche
obligé de faire appel à des financements
privés pour avancer on travailler
correctement
quand on fait de la recherche dite
fondamentale on a de l'argent a par
contre ce qui est très très très
difficile en france et dehors de la de
l'argent pour la recherche clinique et
en particulier thérapeutique puisque en
général ce sont les labos
pharmaceutiques qui payent ce genre de
recherche si on revient la discussion
connaît tout à l'heure sur les liens
d'intérêt avec c'est avec ces labos par
contre c'est très très très difficile
d'avoir de l'argent pour un médicament
générique et qui rapporte rien à
personne et 1
alors qu'une étude clinique
ça coûte très cher donc là on revient
encore à la question des conflits
d'intérêts encore une fois finalement on
n'en sort pas on en revient aussi au
manque de mécanismes de financement
d'une recherche clinique qui n'est pas
sur des médicaments qui seront très
rentable et ça en france on en a pas
d'argent pour ça et beaucoup plus facile
d'être est de tester un nouveau
médicament parce que c'est un
investissement pour une société que un
ancien qui rapporte rien et les
laboratoires vont pas financer puisque
pour l'or intéresse les pesté un nouveau
médicament pas un ancien pourtant là on
est quand même dans une situation de
crise
est-ce que l'urgence de la situation
n'incite pas le gouvernement à faire
plus d'efforts moi ce que j'ai remarqué
depuis le début c'est l'absence totale
de politique claire de dans la recherche
médicale
ordu autour de qu'ovide et nous a pas
échappé que les études type discovery
n'ont rien donné et que la part de la
recherche française dans l'avancement
des connaissances sur sur coville a été
très très très faible et ça c'est une
vraie tragédie mais qui montre bien les
faiblesses de notre système de recherche
médicale et de finance marre aussi
pourtant le gouvernement a annoncé que
25 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
allaient être investis dans la recherche
entre 2025 et 2030
est ce que ça ne paraît pas à la hauteur
des enjeux actuellement en france
oui la loi sur la recherche enfin donne
des objectifs précis de financement et
ça c'est ça c'est vraiment très bien
mais là est ce qui m'a vraiment attristé
c'est que on a été totalement incapable
de lancer des études un peu innovante
sur sûr que vides depuis le mois de mars
et je rappelle quand même que discovery
ça a été une tragédie
c'est un coup de tête je crois 10
millions d'euros pour aucun article
scientifique qui a été publié les
anglais ont montré que la dexaméthasone
c'est la cortisone marchait très bien
d'autres pays ont fait des choses en
france c'est un désastre quand même
justement vous avez été auditionnés par
une commission denquête sénatoriales en
septembre dernier pour donner votre avis
sur la gestion des tests coville 19 et à
l'époque vous aviez pointé du doigt les
errements du gouvernement et des
autorités sanitaires concernant les
tests
est ce que vous estimez avoir été
entendu je ne sais pas si j'ai été
entendu mais je peux vous dire que par
exemple aujourd'hui j'étais j'ai twitté
furieux que deux personnes de mon
laboratoire qui étaient des sujets
contacts ont été testé il ya quelques
jours par un labo lillois qui a été
incapable de rendre en quatre jours des
résultats et ça c'est intolérable
allez le gouvernement paye énormément
les laboratoires privés ou publics
d'ailleurs pour un service qui est
souvent très mauvais et on a des
laboratoires que je connais ce qu'il
faut vraiment 24 heures
mais il y en a d'autres comme celui ci
que j'ai citées dans mon tweet qui a
good quatre jours vous dis bah je sais
pas quand vous aurez les résultats
sujets contacts c'est intolérable
et donc aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation où serviable entre un million
et demi et deux millions de tests par
semaine mais pas toujours faire pour les
gens qu'il le faudrait et surtout pas
assez rapidement et donc à la stratégie
d'isolement et de traçage peut pas
marcher tant qu'on n'aura pas à réussi à
faire mieux d'où l'intérêt des tests
antigénique des tests salivaires
d'autres types de tests puisque les
laboratoires privés qui font des tests
pcr pour beaucoup sont toujours
incapables de faire un travail correct
par manque de moyens par manque de
réflexion sur la stratégie à mener
mon avis est que ils ont acheté des
machines très rapide vu qu'il arrive à
les rentabiliser en quelques mois
par contre ils ont pas engager du
personnel compétent et ils sont mal
organisés et c'est de l'argent
facilement gagné mais la qualité de ces
de ce qui est fait est souvent mauvais
lé pas toujours il ya je connais
vraiment des labos qui font un très bon
travail à lille à lyon par exemple mais
il y en a d'autres qui font des
bénéfices et et travaille mal et le
gouvernement a décidé de donner beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent c'est à dire beaucoup
plus qu'en allemagne par exemple
laboratoire privé pour l'heure pour
qu'ils puissent augmenter leur
production mais a pas été très regardant
sur les objectifs de qualité et le
premier objectif c'est de rendre le
résultat rapidement et toujours en
parlant de stratégie gouvernementale est
ce que vous pensez que ce re confinement
dans lequel on est actuellement et
efficace moi je suis un petit peu
inquiet parce que il ya eu des études
qui sont sortis scientifique beurre dans
un journal de type lens est paru la
semaine dernière qui disait que pour
qu'un confinement soit efficace il faut
que réellement diminue la le travail
présentiel donc en face du télétravail
il faut aussi qu'on diminue
et les déplacements des gens c'est pas
ce qui se fait et j'ai un petit peu peur
qu'on a un faux vrais faux confinement
ce qui veut dire que on va diminuer que
très lentement
la contamination vous savez le fameux
zéro qui vous dit combien de personnes
vous risquer de contaminer si vous êtes
porteur du virus
il a aujourd'hui 2 1 2 1 3 une personne
contamine 1,3 autre personne et donc le
nombre de contaminés augmente chaque
semaine pour qu'on sorte de ce
confinement il faudrait qu'il descendait
à 07 08 puisque le gouvernement a dit il
faut ça on est aujourd'hui à 50000
contaminés par jour il faut descendre à
5000 si on continue comme on fait là moi
j'ai un peu peur qu'on est coincé je
commande jusqu'à la fin janvier mais
vous comprenez pas que le gouvernement
ait finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit d'éviter une crise économique
voilà qui aurait des conséquences
catastrophiques pour le pays et en même
temps d'éviter la propagation du virus
c'est assez compliqué finalement comme
choix ah je vous répète à la place du
gouvernement français en ce moment car
il ya que des mauvaises solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
ont testé 60 millions de français comme
les slovaques wendel de le faire ils ont
testé ce week-end par des tests
antigénique 5 millions ce qui nous
permettra vraiment de savoir à la fin du
confinement quels sont les porteurs qui
reste est de les isoler parce que si on
fait pas ça et bien dans trois mois
quatre noms se retrouvera encore dans un
troisième confinement vous pensez qu'on
peut être confronté à une troisième
vague bas aux états unis sont déjà à la
troisième vague
donc je pense que oui on peut tout à
fait un troisième vague exactement 1
un an après la première puisque vous
avez remarqué quand c'est sorti de la
première vague vers le real mode mais
joueurs et on est rentré dans la
deuxième mort en octobre
donc on pourrait peut-être se sortir de
là de la deuxième vers vers des 5
janvier on peut revenir en
avril à une troisième tant qu'on aura
pas le vaccin
effectivement on a un risque très
important
d'où l'importance de vraiment traquer
les derniers porteurs qu'on n'aura vers
le mois de janvier pour que sa vie de
remonter avec moi c'est tout et c'est
une course contre la montre
c'est tout ce qu'on fait un alors
philippe froguel on arrive déjà presque
à la fin de cet entretien j'avais une
dernière question une question qu'on se
pose tous aujourd'hui où en est la
recherche française actuellement où
est-ce qu'on en est par rapport à
d'autres pays comme l'angleterre vous
qui a enseigné à londres ou même par
rapport à la chine dont on parle
beaucoup
est-ce qu'on a perdu la bataille
finalement face à ces pays-là la
recherche française en tout cas celle
que je connais c'est à dire la médicale
est en déclin et ça tout le monde le dit
même nos autorités
par rapport aux britanniques et aux
allemands on est on est maintenant
troisième voire quatrième
même l'italie fait souvent beaucoup
mieux que nous en recherche recherche
médicale je pense que le système des chu
est à bout de souffle que la plupart de
mes collègues voient des malades font un
peu d'enseignements mais très peu de
recherches alors que dans en angleterre
quand vous êtes professeur de médecine à
vous faites d'abord delà de la recherche
est donc pour l'instant si on ne réforme
pas dans les prochaines années dès 6h
sûrement racontines notre déplacez pas
une question d'argent uniquement
c'est vraiment une question
d'organisation et de sélection des des
professeurs de médecine et des
chercheurs qui ne sont pas dans les
conditions idéales pour faire de la
science même s'ils en ont fait un peu au
début de leur carrière
en fait c'est le contexte de recherche
qui est pas favorable en france
aujourd'hui
oui je pense pas que les français sont
plus mauvais que les autres d'ailleurs
on réussit très bien quand on va dans
les autres pays
simplement c'est très très très dur
pratique en france
les directions de ch une pensée
avant tout des questions financières et
donc la recherche médicale fait ce
qu'elle peut l'inserm s'est fait ce
qu'il peut mais dès que ça revient à
être de recherche très clinique
on est vraiment dans des conditions de
bureaucratie extrême de très grosses
difficultés hors des autorisations est
encore pire même quand on a l'argent
n'arrive pas le débat c'est donc un
constat assez pessimiste et alan
alarmistes sur l'état de la recherche en
france 3 je pense qu'il va falloir
vraiment réformer les chu les chu vous
l'avez sûrement remarqué
aujourd'hui il ya un eu un siège
centrisme et on protège les sièges sur
les réanimations c'est un peu pour ça
qu'on a fait les confinements mais le
service rendu par ces c est sûr or soins
sont assez bons meilleurs soins et pas
bon et donc c'est bien ça que qu'on paye
on voit bien pour le coc vide on a été
incapable incapable de faire de la
recherche clinique sur le co vide
discovery c'est pas la faute du
gouvernement c'est la faute des chu qui
n'ont pas sûr
à voir les patients bon moment et les
analyser correctement
merci beaucoup philippe froguel d'avoir
répondu à toutes ses questions a su
rester france merci beaucoup c'est la
fin de cette grande interview merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez retrouver cet
entretien sur le réseaux sociaux et en
podcast sur notre site internet
rt france point tv quant à moi je vous
retrouve très vite su adapter france
[Musique]